tant de batailles menées au fil des ans et
pourtant aucune d'entre elles comme celle-ci, comment il est
destiné à se détruire ou pouvons-nous
changer qui nous sommes et nous unir est l'
avenir vraiment défini
[Musique]
mutants nous nous trouvons maintenant au
bord de l'extinction vous '  J'aurai besoin d'aller
dans le passé pour mettre fin à cette guerre avant même qu'elle
ne
commence  pris les choses qui comptent le plus
pour moi
peut-être que tu aurais dû te battre plus fort pour
eux
il y a un nouvel ennemi là-bas mutants
tu auras besoin d'une nouvelle arme pour cette guerre je
sais ce que je dois faire c'est nous pour eux
[Musique]
tous  ces années gaspillées à se battre les uns contre les
autres
pas pire beaucoup de gens sont morts des amis
on nous a donné une seconde chance
guidez nous guidez nous
je ne veux pas de votre avenir
nous étions censés les protéger
tu as peur je me souviens de
toi
[Musique]